you have been to medical school you were
a real doctor for quite a long time
and so i'm curious does that knowledge
that you have real skills real abilities
give you confidence
as a show business guy as an actor you
know it kind of does psychologically
because when you're acting like if
you're among like legends like yourself
and it's it's so hard to move very smart
smart move we go easy on you
suck up yeah hey guys asu and then
but what i do you know to calm down my
nerves i'm like these guys are comedy
legends but they don't know how to save
a life you know like those kind of
things
right they can't heal the sick [ __ ]
you know so
i have that little from the cops that's
really the way to say it
yes yes it is that's exactly how i was
taught to say it in med school yeah
actually so you could pull the sick
[ __ ] yes if i could
if i was having like a massive heart uh
problem right now
you would know what to do you'd be able
to open my chest with like a pen knife
get my heart out massage it put it back
in yeah you could do all that i would
open i would say to the nurse or someone
passion
it would be right here it would be andy
andy open that [ __ ] up and then
get me the whatever coronary stint
yeah unless i sew this making that yeah
at first i don't know if i can
die you don't know if you can curse yes
of course you can tom brady said
earlier he hasn't cursed his entire life
then suture them you know
dr kazar
i didn't mean go nuclear sorry sorry
now you're doing this season of dr ken
you're doing more
like medical stuff on the show what
you're examining like real cases that
might come up is that right
yeah it's been a lot of fun and i've
been more active in the writing and
and it's really cool like my wife and i
my wife's also a doctor and we'll kind
of come up with
we'll pitch story ideas like certain
cases that i don't know that
we did we did an episode that mimicked
uh depression and it turned out the
patient had
hypercalcium like high calcium levels in
the blood and this is so much fun to
it's so much fun to put the audience to
sleep with the story but it's so much
fun
to uh it's so much fun to to really
getting depressed just listening to it
no but you know
no but you know what's interesting is
that it's a it's a show it's
entertainment
but what we were used to growing up with
uh you know dads on tv that were doctors
would their business of being a doctor
was completely separate from what was
going on on the show or the sitcom but
you're trying it looks like you're
trying to work in
real medicine yeah no i'm on definitely
this season i'm more on the hunt to kind
of just
keep it more on my mind when i was a
physician was always on medicine
even when i was at home and this season
my wife also works
as a she was also a physician on the
show we work together and that mimic our
real life
me my real-life life we worked in the
same hmo together so
all we do would talk shop 24 7 medicine
it was it was crazy and nerdy it was
one thing i did one thing i didn't know
about you is crazy and nerdy by the way
that's
my autobiography